hello everyone
welcome to rational science directly
from
frankfurt germany um last week
we didn't have a show uh we were
involved with
a little tragedy that happened within
our family
and that's that one of my brothers um
they amputated uh his right leg be
uh above the knee uh because of
diabetes and half his body
was paralyzed so um
you know we were with that issue last
week it's interesting that he's um
he's an atheist and
his brother-in-law you know he married a
japanese woman
and uh the entire family on her side
japanese pretty much all the all the
boys
[Music]
did judo you know they were
buddhists and they were judo
practitioners
okay and there was one of them 17 year
old
and he was quite athletic
and one day he did a somersault in the
air
and he fell on his neck
and overnight a matter of seconds he
became a quadriplegic
the doctor said he might live maybe two
three years
and he lived to at least the age of 52 i
think
he lived like 35 more years
and and it turns out my brother had
talks with him
since he was a buddhist when he was
completely paralyzed sitting in a bed
for the rest of his life
his parents took care of him and my
brother asked him
if he thought that was worth living that
kind of life
and the fellow told him that
he had no problem with it because he was
being punished
in this life and that in his next life
he would come back in better shape as
who knows whatever
and so it gives you a little bit of a
lesson that
maybe religious people here have an
advantage over
atheists who don't believe in a second
chance
pretty much right and so um now my
brother's in that situation
and the question is whether he would
choose to die
or to live like that for the rest of his
life
and that's a question for you how would
you do it or what would you do in
in a similar situation and i'll put the
the uh the issue the same issue
in a different context for you to ponder
would you like to be the last human on
earth
okay uh here you are all alone
no one to take care of you maybe you get
sick
you know the the problem with people who
are all alone they have to take care of
their own
health and it's easy to talk about
health when you're 30 years old but it's
a little different when you're
60 70 or 80. and so think about that as
well
okay okay so let's get on with some of
the
questions that people ask regarding
extinction
and that subject but before well let me
start it with this
okay um i i have a statement uh that i
always put out there i said we are the
last generations
of humans on earth a lot of people ask
me about that especially
everybody wants to know when tell them
i'm not uh
an astrologer okay i don't do astrology
okay so uh what is a generation well a
generation
is it just means that we don't have a
long time to go
you don't have too much time ahead of us
whatever that means to you
everybody has to use their own criterion
right whatever notion you have
of time of how much time it's going to
take
for the world to collapse for the global
economy to collapse
and subsequently you know be followed by
the collapse of the food chain okay
and so um yeah i don't give a date
because i consider a generation again a
very general term
i have to put something in there and i
put the word generation meaning that
we're very close to extinction that's
all that generation means
okay and i gave the example
the other day i think it was of um
of a uh was it a galileo
and um and newton
you know were they of the same
generation they were both from the 17th
century
but galileo died the year that newton
was born
should we consider them of the same
generation now that we look back
at that piece of history or should we
consider other people
being of the same generation as galileo
and newton so you know again what is a
generation well it's a very vague term
and it's deliberately vague in my theory
because
i don't give a date for extinction okay
let's move on to the questions now yeah
here we have a fellow says
do you accept that catastrophic events
might have been the trigger
for mass extinctions for example the
asteroid impact before the end of the
dinosaurs for example right
setting off a food collapse that was
latent
or in the making because there seems to
be a lot of evidence for such
catastrophic events and i wonder how
this fits
in with your proposed mechanism well no
i'm saying that catastrophes have
absolutely nothing none of them
have anything to do with any of the mass
extinctions of the past
mother nature does not work through
catastrophes especially uh you know
coming out of the sky
came out of the sky uh
asteroids comets uh supernovas
um all those things from the skies
okay none of those ever happened
volcanoes you know in the case of
permian one of the most
popular ones is the volcano theory that
there were some volcanoes or
maybe even some
underwater eruptions
okay and so i'm saying none of those had
anything at all to do with extinction
catastrophes don't have anything to do
with extinction
and the main argument i've got against
that is that you cannot
you cannot with a catastrophic accident
explain selectivity you cannot explain
how mother nature got rid of some
animals plants and animals and left
other plants and animals alive
and when you look at the history it just
by
sheer coincidence it's the old plants
and animals that
vanished in a mass extinction and the
new ones that continued
and that happened in every extinction
you can't produce that kind of
selectivity chronological selectivity
with any kind of catastrophic accident
so you so you cannot explain selectivity
with catastrophes period
so they have absolutely nothing to do
with mass extinctions
what you've got to explain really is how
a food chain
disappears and i know what remains
because that's exactly what happened
and of course if one food chain
disappears
well you have to believe that what
happened was that the primary production
is what disappeared essentially not that
it disappeared completely
but the islands shrank other plants took
over
any animals that were tied to those
shrinking islands
those were the ones that disappeared
that's essentially the theory
okay and so no in fact here i have a
chart a little graph there it's known as
the cretaceous terrestrial revolution
which i have shown
in the past and it's when the flowering
plants took over the land
which are the red uh graft there and you
can see that
uh the angiosperms uh
muscled all the other plant types of
plants aside
in the last half of the cretaceous okay
and when you look at that you say okay i
see what happened
if the dinosaurs were tied to the cycads
and to
the conifers in general well you can see
how those uh
suffered greatly at the hands of the
angiosperms
okay so it's the gymnosperms that
disappeared essentially and today we
have
relatively few gymnosperms on the planet
and all mammals they don't eat
gymnosperms they eat angiosperms
okay so so it is a food chain phenomena
that's what i'm saying that mass
extinctions are
okay so again that's
my take on that my five cents worth
that's my theory
uh another question issue a person
raises he says
birth rate is low due to empowering
women
not urban urbanization uh
well i think he's uh still stuck in the
stone age
uh he doesn't want women equality he
thinks that's bad
and yeah all i can say is every age had
a different
uh type of family
okay we had patriarchy we had matriarchy
we had
um before that right we had um
nuclear family and today we have more or
less the bachelor
that's the that's where we're headed you
know there will be
no marriages in the future it'll be
casual sex maybe here and there
and uh hopefully nothing no no
productivity why because we moved to the
cities we have
high density and again it's what i
showed with a couple of those
videos last time where you see the
fruits
or it could be a vegetable as well and
the
bacteria just you know first multiply
and then as a
as they multiply and you have more
bacteria well then the whole thing
shrinks and eventually collapses to zero
and unless those bacteria can move on to
some other
mountain of food or whatever well they
die as well that's the end of them
so that's essentially explains what is
known as density dependent birth rates
okay the more um
the the bacteria or any animal for that
matter i mean
bacteria are kind of in between but if
you take any animal
and you have lots of them
the more you have of them in a given
size pen or whatever eventually
at some point the curve will turn around
and they'll start
start having fewer children fewer
offspring
okay and that's known as density
dependent birth rates
humans are have been shown to have
to suffer to experience density
dependent birth rates as well
that means that when you get into a city
you're going to have to find fewer and
fewer children
and if you want to see children you got
to go more out into the country
it's a that transition that's created
the
low birth rates okay another question
another uh
issue paul says
as a marxist you will never understand
money
and therefore your theory of money and
food will always fail
ask yourself marxist why do people
produce
that is a question you do not understand
oh i see okay
it is called self-interest okay why do
you produce these videos
for the money you get which helps you to
satisfy
your self-interest well first of all
there seems to be a contradiction there
because you're saying i
i cannot understand money
or why people do things and then you say
you're doing this because
so it looks like i do understand maybe
right right
okay but no uh there's a different
argument no i don't do these videos for
money
absolutely not i don't make i don't make
any money out of this
some i have some patreon supporters and
i
do thank them but uh that's just to keep
the channel alive i don't make
i can't live off of that for sure i'd
starve to death okay before the
extinction
no i do this uh because i absolutely
love
physics and i do a lot of research on
these subjects
also extinction by the way and and so i
do this just for the fun of it i
i have no reason to do this other than
that it's a
subject i enjoy and i'm very passionate
about
and so that's it that's that's the end
of it so
you know this notion that people do
everything for money
uh no there are other reasons
and i had another question along the
same lines
and uh the file says the following let's
see if i can get this up here
oh my god on the other side give me a
second here
he says um money is what motivates
industrial espionage
i used to be a spy so that's what he's
referring to uh regardless of
whatever pitiful secondary
justifications you come up with
while you're in the dark okay uh
wrong again just like the other fellow
they're both quite wrong
uh especially when when you're a marxist
i used to be a marxist
in other words in the sense that
i believed that you know that communism
was going to take over the world and i
did support that
during many years of my life at least 20
20 plus years
and i didn't do it for money absolutely
not
had nothing to do with my i never got a
penny for that
for for for that kind of spying in other
words
uh in in my case i approached the cubans
and the reason they were willing to work
with me is
first i told them that who i was you
know and what i was doing
uh and what i could do for them and then
i was doing it for free
why because i was a marxist and so once
that was cleared up and they could
verify that through
the fact that i had uh requested a visa
a permanent resident visa to go to cuba
when i was young and so they saw that
they saw that i was
in the communist party of argentina and
so they
decided that they were going to work
with me and throughout that time i never
made a penny
it was never done for money at all in
fact it turns out that when i
turned myself over to the cia and the
fbi the fbi one day
mr king jim king who was handling my
case he was the
case agent from austin texas
and we were discussing one day at my
table uh
in my uh dining room and you know i
i don't know how the conversation came
out and i told him at one point i said
you know i didn't do this for money
and he looked at me straight in my eyes
and he said
yeah we know and it's like
he couldn't believe that someone would
would do it for
anything other than money and what you
have to understand is people do things
for
ideology and so this notion that you
have that
everyone does it is a prostitute maybe
like you
who who only does things for money i
mean i don't know how far you're willing
to
to go uh you know what are you willing
to do maybe have some
safe sex maybe with someone for money
you know people do things for things
other than money
and they will not do certain things even
for money
so to say that everything is done for
money is
is just uh insane and i'm sure that
you don't believe it yourself okay so no
um
i never did anything for money as far as
uh
you know the spying business the other
issue you should be aware of you know
when i was in prison i got 11 people
out of prison which owe me their lives
okay i guess they connected me back uh
jailhouse lawyers who charge to
help inmates their fellow inmates and
they charge quite a bit they charge like
two thousand dollars to handle their
cases and do their
motions in court i did it for over a
hundred
cases while i was in prison i did that
almost on a daily basis i had uh
i dedicated some time to do motions for
inmates
and i never charged them a single penny
not one penny
i did it because i wanted to screw the
system
i wanted to get back at the system
partly and because some of these
guys had um i think they had a valid
case
and again i was able to get 11 people
out that never
had any idea that they would ever be out
of prison and i got them out
as a jailhouse lawyer and i got them out
for free
they felt so compelled to to
pay me back for what i had done for them
that they would give me whatever they
could maybe stamps or
envelopes or whatever that you know i
could use
sometimes they would bring coffee or
stuff like that but i never charged them
a penny
so uh people don't do things only for
money and certainly not me
i don't do things for money rarely do i
do something for money
i did my regular work at amd for money
but
not spying okay let me move on to
another question here fellow says
humans were surviving long before we
invented money
yeah we were surviving on something
called food
otherwise we wouldn't be surviving okay
and now we didn't trade food so we
didn't use it as money
when we lived off of food exclusively
like you know when we were hunters
and yeah so we were surviving but we
were surviving not because of money we
were surviving because of food
and today the problem is that food is
produced only
because of money and so i don't know if
you can tie two and two together there
but
uh it turns out that if there is no
money there is no food
okay and another fella asked along the
same lines uh a question along that same
line or
makes a comment he says uh removing all
money won't remove
all food okay
however it likely will reduce food
supply considerably
i'm sure there will be a lot of pockets
of survival
and again this is where we have obeying
problem people don't believe
that if money disappears it cannot
rationalize us that if money disappears
food disappears
no one will produce or distribute food
whatever food you have
you keep to yourself whatever food the
farmer is planting he will keep to
himself and he better
be able to defend it which he won't be
able to because he's going to have acres
of land he's got to have acres to feed
himself and his family if he's got a
family right and he's not going to be
able to patrol his whole
garden from city folks which will just
run over his
land and just take away his corn his
lettuce whatever he's got there
his cows he's not going to be able to
protect
his holdings all by himself and he can
have a group of people it still won't
help because he's going to be fighting
thousands of people a lot of them armed
others will just come and steal whatever
he's got there's no way he can patrol
the land
so uh there won't be any food after the
global economy collapses
and we have no money on the planet no
one does trade anymore
and it's incredible people have trouble
understanding that
and here i'm not yet at the point where
you say well how does money disappear
right now that's an irrelevant question
i'm saying if god comes in with his
magic wand makes
all money disappear just by magic nobody
believes in money no one
trusting god anymore you know and god we
don't trust uh
at that point uh we stop producing
food and whatever food there's on the
planet that's it
and you know whether hidden or out in
the open and then
whoever has it that guy lives a little
more than the other guy probably and
then they have to defend that food
but no one will be producing food
because you won't have
time to wait for the harvest first and
second
you know while you're planting someone
comes over and says okay thanks for the
job
here why don't you take off now and i'll
collect the harvest
you know defense will be the problem you
know
you can't you can't you won't have 9-1-1
you won't have the courts you won't have
the police you won't have
the military everything breaks down when
there is
no money money is what holds it together
today
okay so no rich person will be able to
compel a poor person to do anything
because what is he going to bribe him
with
money okay so money is the key issue
when money disappears that's it for all
of us
okay and so here's another issue
question
fella says says everything would
have to be extinct for your theory to
work and everything does not go extinct
in past die-off events
well everything did not go extinct
because
everything does not need to go extinct
so i don't know where he got that
in fact when one food chain disappeared
the other one continued
rolling why because the food chain that
disappeared had nothing to do with the
food chain that kept go
that's what it's all about i mean let's
just
make an assumption here let's assume
that when mammals essentially that's
going to be the
sixth mass extinction uh what it's going
to be about
mammals disappearing when mammals
disappear
and let's assume the insects take over
the land okay just
an assumption here okay so the insects
take over the land
are we are we gonna kill all the insects
no
we're probably not gonna be able to wipe
them out uh we're gonna
be eating uh mammals you know cows pigs
uh
maybe chickens and uh some other animal
that we have out there and that's it we
wipe them all out
they're out of the you know how
they they go into extinction we might
even kill all the lions we'll kill all
the elephants
anything that walks will kill and then
we'll kill each other and we're out of
the picture
and the insects can take over the land
you know
they start radiating you know those
insects that can adjust to weeds because
the foods
that we grow today the the plants that
we grow today
primarily the grasses are going to
disappear with us that's why we died
because there were no more grasses
or very few of them and what continues
are the
maybe the weeds or some other plant that
goes out there maybe some carnivorous
plant or whatever
and whatever little uh insect that maybe
feeds on that
those will radiate they will occupy
their niches and eventually grow maybe
grow to bigger size
sizes like uh in the carboniferous you
had uh
what is it dragonflies which had meter
long
wings and they're little airplanes
okay so we don't know what's coming next
but if assuming it's the
insects for sure we're not gonna wipe
out all the insects okay
no one's gonna take the trouble to to
hunt for insects out there
okay and so yeah one food chain
disappears another one stays
so yeah all everything does not
disappear with a mass extinction so
i don't know where this guy got the idea
that everything has to disappear if food
disappears now
there what's food for us disappears but
with food for something else that we
don't eat or have anything to do with
those
are untouched you know nothing will
happen to them
uh another issue another question fellow
says
ah i fell on the other side so
touchy okay here it is
fella says also food will never end raw
meat from
almost all animals can keep mankind
going forever
so the guy really believes that uh
that mammals that is primarily what we
eat in terms of meat
we obviously be chickens and fish and so
on
but in general uh you know he's saying
all the animals will stay there
and uh we'll have meat forever
my god and they really believe us they
they really think that this is the case
and no
one issue is that we grow a lot of these
or you know raise these animals
uh why do we raise them well because you
know we eat them we kill them and eat
them
some people think that's immoral to not
even hunt them that just to grow them in
a pendant just kill them at our leisure
uh but yeah all that's done for money
you know butchering is done for money
that's the bottom line and so um you
know
money is gone there's no reason for this
person to have cattle or pigs or
or chickens or even fish you know so
so no when money disappears there's no
reason to
raise these animals for the market and
if the guy grows him for himself
he better watch out that you know he
doesn't get uh
visits from thousands of people from the
city okay that's the issue there
okay and all i can say is what i always
try to say
and very few people address this some do
okay
and it's this one that you got to do
extinction 101 before you do 102
everybody's an expert on how humans
won't die
no one's an expert on how animals in the
past
did die okay so please address
extinction 101 which is the issue really
here mass extinction
and don't go so quickly to human
extinction figure out if you can tell me
what caused the extinction of animals in
the past and hopefully you will not use
any of those catastrophes you know
supernovas and uh asteroids and comets
and all that kind of stuff
okay so let's get to the
issue today the issue today is
uh holy geometry some call it sacred
geometry sacred what is sacred about
geometry
i mean are we supposed to pray here what
is this
sacred geometry and so yeah they have
these notions and i think it's
it comes from people who are deeply
religious
mystics way deep inside them
and they want to think of themselves as
scientists as mathematicians as
geometers whatever
and they they come across as
no no i'm a scientist and what they are
is simply deeply religious
people okay well let me start with uh
where essentially i ended up the other
day with just showing what's
uh the problem with geometry so we have
a oh sorry
got the wrong one here
um give me a second here
got the one from the questions uh at the
end of the show
okay let me get to the conclusions here
okay and uh so those were conclusions
about geometry essentially
and essentially mathematical figures are
not figures okay
that's uh the arguments i made the the
for the last month or so
uh math physics only has itineraries
uh that's what i showed there in fact uh
here's a couple uh i'll put it side by
side so you see what i'm talking about
for those who miss the shows
okay a point is not a point a line is
not a line
a point is a location and a line is a
bunch of locations meaning an itinerary
okay so uh we're not talking about
geometric figure
so we need to know what a figure is
before we do all this and
in geometry today we have no figures
because they're all done with
motion okay and time and so a line
circle etc are a bunch of locations
that's all they are all math solids are
hollow
okay they're not one of them is a solid
uh the tesseract which i had here as
well let me show you that
give me a second here tesseract there
you can see
uh is uh not four-dimensional
what you see there in front of you is a
three-dimensional
cube on a two-dimensional
platform you can say and then the one on
the one that they define and describe
you can see
it's supposedly some eight cubes that
come out of nowhere
magic wand and so it's nonsense
okay because uh that's not a figure
it's it's uh some kind of movie of
something
of a cube turning into eight cubes
that's that's what that is
no the tesseract is uh if it's a figure
it should
be standing still it should not be
moving and it should look
something like the one where it says
what they illustrate
that blue double cube or
nested cubes that you see there and
that is a three dimensional again two
nested cubes
onto a 2d platform that's all that is
objectively okay you don't have to read
more into what you see in front of you
okay hypersphere not equal to
four-dimensional either as you can see
there's just a balloon that it's growing
that's all it is
time is supposedly the fourth dimension
that is invoked to
make that uh image there taurus a bunch
of locations
okay that's all it is itineraries and uh
when a stroke
when rotating square cubed tesseract or
any of those
mathematicians are spinning motion
itself
time itself right okay so that's where i
started but
again we have to go back to find out
what is a figure
and the answer there is that we have to
define what an object is
we have to do that for the purposes of
physics and we do that here
and we need to know what an object is
for the purposes of physics we
have to find a criterion that's the
issue or criteria if it's more than one
and the main two that everybody use are
see and touch
everybody thinks that an object is that
which you can see and touch
they also say that an object that exists
is that which you can see and touch
okay and uh so the word object in the
word exists are synonyms when
they use it like that and we're saying
that no you
can't use c or touch because not all
objects can be seen not all objects can
be touched
whereas all objects had better have
shape
it's the universal property all objects
have
shape okay and none of those other ones
qualify you know it's not a
an object is not that which has mass or
volume or that moves or that what it's
made out of
um it's not the subject of a sentence
it's not a noun
uh it's not that which has color or you
know
whatever anyway you want to put that uh
it's not an object that
it's not that which exists okay and some
people also say that concepts exist
like love exists you know no not in
physics and physics only objects can be
said to exist
and it's not that which is 3d okay
because there are 2d
objects 2d objects have shape and
they're not 3d
okay so there's all those are rejected
the only one that we can use in
in physics is uh shape
that's the criterion now we don't have
to define shape
because we're only comparing it against
the other
criteria okay that's why we don't have
to define shape
and physically we don't continue
defining forever just to please the
devil's advocate all we do is we say
look we got to choose a criteria
all right criterion which one are you
going to choose and when we have to
choose a shape it's the only one that's
applicable
all the others fail you can't use them
to define
the word object that's the one we're
concerned about not the word shape we're
concerned about what is an object
you don't know what shape is go to
kindergarten show them a cube show them
a
ball of the same volume same mass same
everything and
ask the kids what is the difference
between these two and they'll say
it's a shape they'll teach you what
shape is
okay so if you don't know what shape is
go to a kindergartener
kindergarten and you'll they'll teach
you okay
okay you must have missed the class okay
uh a person uh
asks then he says well does the
mandelbrot uh
set have a shape and okay
with if you look at uh if you look it up
you'll find an
image that looks like the one you see
there and i look at that and say well
you know that has shape
we're done so if if that's what they
call a mandelbrot
and we'll stop there we won't put
anything before or after that we'll call
that a mandelbrot we can call it
x as well we say yeah x does have shape
straight forward we're done okay what's
the problem well the problem with
mandelbrot is
and less like the problem with the word
shadow
you have to find out what the word
shadow means and you got to find out
what a mandelbrot
set is or means or stands for what is
this
it turns out that you got to use that
equation to
calculate points where to put the points
on that image
okay that's what that equation is all
about and some say that it's just
as famous or not quite but at least it's
just as important or whatever as e
equals m c squared
also which was uh attributed to
einstein which i think it should not
have been because
that equation existed before einstein
but um you know this uh
uh mandelbrot it's got that equation
that's how they calculate each point
then they take that point they
and they calculate it again and they
just do this iteration okay
forever and and so uh
the mandelbrot set is something
in motion so if that's what mandelbrot
said or just
madden bro if you just want to call it
mando brought means or stands for
that's not a geometric figure what i
have in front of us
is a figure it's a it has shape and
i don't have to do anything with it i
have to look deeper into it
and find out if it's got little points
in between two points we don't care
about any of that
we say does that have shape yeah it's
got shape it's got it's contoured all
around it's got shape
we're done so that what's in front of us
does have shape
and is an object a figure all these are
synonyms okay
a thing okay now what what do they
say what is uh mando brought according
to these people well they say something
else
this is what they they put it in motion
and here you can see a little image of
this
okay and you can see how this thing is
growing
okay and what you got to do is zoom in
zoom in zoom in zoom in
all the way okay and all you do is all
day long is just zoom in on this
and you can see these patterns in there
okay
and so the question is is that a
geometric figure what you're staring at
and the answer is no because it doesn't
stop moving okay
so here you see it you see how it's just
zooming in all the way
uh forever that's essentially what
they're saying here that you know that's
what a manual broad set
is and no that is the one on the right
is not a geometric figure
first of all because it doesn't stand
still okay
um it's got time involved it's got
motion involved and an
object is not that which moves it's not
that which has time
an object is what you see on the left a
that which has shape
okay the one on the right we don't know
if that has shaped because it keeps
moving we don't know
what we're staring at it's got to be
standing still in order
for us to determine whether it is a
geometric
figure okay and then um
let me show you this
no here it is uh there's uh this uh
description uh for these kinds of
patterns that you see on the right that
says by the end the magnifi
the the magnification of the original
images
3e to the 2159
power right and yes that is a 3 with 2
159 zeros after it to zoom into an
image smoothly you must magnify it
exponentially
in this case the magnification doubles
every 1.5 seconds
the human mind has great difficulty
comprehending exponentials
uh for comparison the width of the
observable
observable universe is about 9e 26
meters
okay okay so um so
uh what these people are saying that you
got to zoom in and that's how you create
any of these images and there's several
of these uh you know i mean it's
that's the mandelbrot that's probably
the most famous one
but here you have some other sacred
geometries i call them holy geometries
okay
um people make these videos you can look
them up those are the titles of the
videos those are the images the icons
they put out there
and you can see they have all these
fancy pictures there that a lot of
people like to
uh look at they're like kind of
hypnotized by them
they love to look at this stuff and you
know just
zooming in into their eyes and i guess
with a little music in the background
they fall asleep and they say oh that
was so nice
and maybe and you know some of these
have uh
thousands hundreds of thousands and
millions of viewers
and not only viewers i mean followers
and you say well
what do these people have in their minds
is this just just to
relax and look at these you can call it
art
is that what it's all about i mean what
does this have to do with geometry what
does it have to do
with physics or science is this how it's
put
forward or is it just put out there as
art is that what all this sacred
geometry this holy geometry is about
okay
and so yeah uh you know a lot of these
people uh
they just uh would like to watch this
stuff
and so i call them you know these i say
these people
are religious folks they just look at
these patterns they're hypnotized by
them
and this is what they like to see they
like to see all these patterns
and that's fine i mean you know if you
like art that's great i have no problem
with that
but you know to call it geometry and to
say that this has
something to do with geometry with
figures or that this has something to do
with science that or with physics
absolutely no this has absolutely
nothing to do
with physics you want art fine
you know but why bring it into physics
why bring it to
sneak it in through geometry and say
well this is geometry we calculate all
this with
or we design these patterns with
mathematical equations
and then we put it in motion we have a
little stuff zooming in in front of our
eyes
yeah if you want to hypnotize someone i
guess that works right
is that what science is about you know
again
science is about explaining and this
certainly doesn't explain anything
okay is this what some of these
geometric figures look like and they're
um
like the mandelbrot set that you saw a
minute ago okay
and you can see these are different ones
that i've just made a collage of and you
can see how they're just zooming in
on all these patterns so what is is this
this is art great uh you know he who
likes to watch this stuff uh
fine you can do this all day as far as
i'm concerned but this has nothing to do
with physics
okay and so yeah i think these people uh
when they bring it into geometry and
they call it geometry they're kind of
trying to sneak it into physics like
saying oh i'm a scientist
no no i can i agree that you're an
artist that i can agree with i cannot
agree that
you you're doing science by showing me
this zoom
into this so-called sacred geometry
simply because you have an equation
that plots the points that make these
patterns
and all the all these these mandelbrot
sets and
all these images are really what they're
doing is they're saying
let's let's uh take the microscope and
zoom in
ever higher and so you go from i don't
know a thousand x microscope
uh to a sam to maybe atomic force
microscope you can
zoom maybe tomorrow we'll invent
something more powerful or maybe some
kind of telescope that looks in there
and so all you keep doing is just uh
looking at the fjords
so to speak and making the fjords
more visible and then you're measuring
each little nuke and cranny and in those
fjords
that's that's what the what it's all
about and so this
what does this have to do with science
with physics
and or geometry assuming you want to
introduce geometry is
part of physics you know again the part
of geometry that belongs to physics is
the figure
not the equation not the relation what
belongs to physics is the figure
the rest belongs to math and there is
no such thing as mathematical physics
math is math physics is physics
you want to do math you want to
calculate these things and get
entertained by the art
well that's one thing don't say that
you're doing physics or that you're a
scientist
scientist is a guy who explains
something that's why we have to
distinguish
an explainer from a describer you know
the guy who goes to the art gallery he's
describing
he's not explaining anything he's just
looking at a picture
and saying oh it's got the blue here and
the red there in this line here and the
other one is straight and the other one
is crooked
you know that that's the description art
art is worthless as far as explanation
is concerned
okay okay um
so here we have um another
type of these sacred geometries it's
known as the [ __ ]
curve or the [ __ ] uh coke
i guess a coke snowflake okay and uh
here's the more or less the description
of this and essentially how you
build this thing okay it says you start
with an equilibrium
equilibrium equilibrium lateral
triangle and on each side you take a
piece that you substitute two pieces
that are now
longer than the original piece and for
those two pieces
you substitute two pieces that are each
longer than the original piece
you do this over and over again you get
the same shape
but now each line has that little
triangular bump on it
you break it again and again and again
each time you break it the line gets
longer
every iteration every cycle you are
adding
on another little triangle imagine
iterating that process of adding little
bits infinitely
many times what you end up with is
something that
that that's infinitely long okay
notice they use this word infinite and
it says the
curve was a paradox to the i the curve
appears to be finite by but
mathematically
it is infinite which means that it
cannot
be measured okay and here you see
again a dynamic version of the
curve or snowflakes let me see if i can
get this thing up here here it is
you can see uh what it looks like
okay they like to watch these things
they like to hypnotize themselves with
it
so what's the problem i have with uh
some of these
uh things let me get myself in here
the problem i have is this notion of
infinity
uh there's nothing infinite about what
you saw there
first of all the word infinite is a word
is an adjective
and what these people are trying to say
is that they're saying
incessantly that's what they're using
that's the notion they're using but
they're
using the word infinite in lieu of the
word incessant or incessantly the adverb
incessantly
and what they're saying is if you do
this incessantly if you do this
over and over again if you do it
incessantly perpetually
uh forever okay
um then you're gonna get that those
patterns and you're gonna be
again looking at the nukes and crannies
of the fjord that you're
zeroing in or zooming in on okay and you
can do this over and over and see more
fjords
more little nukes and crannies and you
say well you can't measure that
why because it all depends on your
measuring stick how
how big or how small you make it okay
and the more you see the smaller you
make your stick
and within that you
you expand that a billion times and now
you got to get another stick to measure
the nukes and crannies there and so on
down the line
and so they they call it infinitely well
the the image is not infinite all
objects all figures are finite
but what these people are saying is that
the itineraries
are infinite okay using that word
meaning that you can walk incessantly
around this
uh perimeter because
uh there are more points in between any
two points
that's essentially what they're saying
with with all this so you can find more
points between any two points
that make up the uh perimeter which make
up
really the itinerary around the
perimeter
of the uh imaging question and so
they say well from a mathematical point
of view
you know if you keep putting numbers in
there and calculating well you can go on
forever
it's it's incessant okay you can
continue putting points
or numbers as much as you want that's
got
nothing to do with the word infinite
which is an adjective that
is used to qualify objects and there is
no
object which is infinite okay
all objects are finite so the word
infinite for the purposes of physics is
an oxymoron
you can only use it with objects you
cannot talk about infinite love
not in not in science okay you can talk
about an
infinite table but there is no such
monster as an infinite table because all
tables are finite
so an infinite object is an oxymoron
because what you're saying is an
infinite finite essentially okay that's
what it comes down to
so infinite is a word outlawed in
science
okay you can use the word incessant if
you're going to be doing math
or talking about itineraries or about
incessant
motion perpetual motion or whatever you
can talk about it
moving incessantly that's one issue you
can't use the word
uh infinite in that context the only way
you can use the word infinite with
objects and there is no such thing as an
infinite object
that's the bottom line okay
uh let's see if we can get to the
questions today some of the
questions people asked
and again here's the this fellow he says
uh
says i asked three questions this was
during my uh
or the monthly recap with
anz my son last time and he says i asked
three questions twice and they were
skipped over
oh i'm so sorry excuse us okay yeah
how do roasts make the poison uh spot
in uh fresnel diffraction how do ropes
make
fellow taxes how to roast make the
toroidal pattern and block wall in
magnetism
i want to add another question how do
ropes make the frequencies of different
color
light okay let's see how we answer this
okay we have a couple answers here for
this gentleman
and here's the first one okay and
it goes like this because that you know
we might
also look at other participants okay uh
questions and comments that they make
and no one has a monopoly over the
airspace here okay so
we can't just look at one guy and say oh
we're just going to answer all your
questions
alone then the questions this fellow is
asking you know a little interest in
physics and highly specialized a lot of
the visitors aren't interested in these
subjects at all
okay so it's not like we're going to
drop other subjects which are more
popular or more
down to earth and just answer these
highly specialized questions on the on
the
run okay and most visitors are not even
aware or care to be aware of what those
far-fetched mathematical issues are
because all these are essentially
mathematical questions okay that's what
this file wants to know he doesn't want
to know a mechanism because he's not
interested in mechanisms and i'll go
over that in a second
he's just interested in uh
in getting a mathematical type of answer
for these things then the issues have no
current rational explanation for this
individual's religion of mathematics
okay
how does he explain any of these
phenomena does he have an explanation
for this
i mean if he wants an explanation does
he have one to begin with
i mean he challenging uh whether we have
an explanation
and like saying he does and he's saying
we don't
okay so let's go through each one of
these okay
here's the poison okay
and this is the answer here what is a
poisson spot okay
a bright point uh this is the from the i
think the wikipedia
right point that appears at the center
of a circular object's shadow
due to what fresnel diffraction
okay so it's it's just a diffraction a
specialized type of diffraction
and we've explained uh diffraction in
the past okay
and the way you find it today and there
you see it this spot played an important
role
in what in the discovery of the wave
nature of light
and is a common way to demonstrate that
light behaves as a wave
and the question here is there is no
physical object called a wave
wave is a verb it's not a noun for the
purposes of physics you can't say that
light is a wave that it waves that
there's a wavy motion that
behaves as a wave yeah you can say that
you cannot say that light
is a wave and until we know what light
is we cannot explain anything about
light especially diffraction
you cannot say well light moved as a
wave whatever light is but it moved as a
wave and that's how we do
diffraction you know interference uh
fringes and so on
uh interference patterns that's not an
explanation you need to know
you need to be able to propose what
physical entity mediates light
and that's the first step if you don't
have a you don't have an
object that can do light you don't have
a theory
you don't even have a theory now you can
say particles assuming they're real
particles like
corpuscles classical corpuscles then yes
you can try to explain it
with core puzzles but you cannot say
wave because there's no such thing as
wave and you cannot say that your core
puzzles
are really quantum particles which are
not particles at all which are just
equations and uh you know
what is it uh wave functions
you know that's nonsense those are not
physical objects
and quantum mechanics does not have a
physical object at all so
there is no theory of quantum mechanics
all there is a description
that's all it is and descriptions are
not science science is
explanations and so there is no such
thing as a wave so the onus shifts
to this individual to explain the poison
spot in um
in rational terms okay in other words
without reification without
concretization turning a concept into an
object
okay so you can't use the word wave
please explain
what physical object created was on spot
that's the question
and if you can't answer that question
well you know you don't have a theory
we do have a theory and we have
explained uh
diffraction in the past many times in
fact and
no problem because we do have a physical
object it's called a rope
and rope two strand rope yeah you can
explain uh interference one rope with
another rope
which is what the poison spot is it's a
diffraction pattern and diffraction is
done with physical
objects okay light is a physical
object and that's where the problem is
people say you know
what do you mean a physical object i
can't see it i can't touch it
yeah because an object is not that which
you can see or touch that's the wrong
definition
and the correct definition or the
scientific definition
is that which has shape a rope
meets that condition okay fellow taxes
let's see what that is
okay and here uh we look it up also at
the
uh wikipedia this is what you find you
find uh phillip taxes the arrangement of
leaves on a plant stem
okay especially if they're curled around
that's what these people usually
talk about you know philotastic spirals
okay
form a distinctive class of patterns in
nature
and let's find out how they're formed
that's what comes next the pattern of
leaves on a plant
is ultimately controlled by the local
depletion of the plant
hormone auxin in certain uh areas of
meristem of the meristem and it goes out
there and
then explains how these
philotex patterns are formed and
you know i don't see where
we have to explain anything with with
the rope here
okay all these people are saying is that
there is a hormone
that is causing this that causes the
plants to curve
okay and to troll around and to spiral
but uh we go the extra mile and we do
have
uh the following okay we do have
if you go to the book why god doesn't
exist my book
uh you'll see uh something that looks
like this
uh and that's collagen and also in the
case
uh in the one on the upper right
uh you'll see the water molecule
essentially how uh
how water is uh connected in other words
how oxygen is connected to
hydrogen uh in in water
and what you see is the hydrogen bond
and hopefully that bond is a physical
entity
and we're saying it's the rope okay and
then you have the
covalent bonds and those are where you
have merged cells
electron shells that encapsulate the uh
nucleus of the atom
and at the bottom you see collagen which
is uh a
again a stringy type thing okay
and uh the question is how are all those
atoms connected
if um if they form collagen
if if if all these atoms
are just loose you know then you would
have a molecule called collagen
the reason we have the stringy molecule
is because they're all connected and so
yeah we do have
an explanation for that and the
explanation does come from
the fact that all atoms in the universe
are interconnected physically
then you can explain you know how these
molecules form
but to say that that molecule over there
or that atom like hydrogen in the case
of water is connected to oxygen over
here
from far away from a distance well what
is connecting them
why doesn't the hydrogen fly away why
doesn't the oxygen fly away
and so you hopefully there's a physical
interconnection between those two atoms
you know so if you have 2h and 1 0 well
you you have the water molecule why
doesn't the h fly away wasn't the oxygen
fly away aren't those
gases you know usually in gaseous state
if you have o2
and h2 don't they fly away so
that's the issue the issue is how do you
form a molecule if you're not going to
put some interconnection between the
atoms
okay and that's essentially what we
explain with the rope
uh model okay
and regarding frequency that he asks how
do you do
frequency with a rope again we've
explained this in the past
and here it is let me make this a little
bigger and it's
um we do it with the prism here it's
very easily explained with that
uh you know in the case of quantum
mechanics it has no explanation because
in uh you have either waves or you have
particles which are the two on the top
and in the case of waves wave is not a
physical object so you haven't
explained how light has uh
frequency and wavelength you know
because you don't know what the
physical object is there is no physical
object called wave and you have to
identify that physical object before you
can talk about waves
what is wavy that's the question
everybody has asked for now
what hundreds of years and in the case
of particles well if they're particles
well yeah
corpuscles you know classical corpuscles
fine you can try to
address that but see uh in quantum they
don't have corpuscles so what you're
seeing here is the classical model
assuming that we're talking about real
corpuscles little balls
well there's too many questions to
explain you cannot explain
wavelength if you don't have waves and
in the case of particles you would have
to move them up and down because
uh the trans transverse motion or wavy
motion
of the waves that's what's called the
transverse wave
you cannot reproduce it with those
particles why would the particle go up
why would the particle go down
what physical object is pushing the
particles up and down to create this
up and down wavy motion you know for for
example the electric field or for the
magnetic field
you cannot explain with particles
because you cannot explain the motion of
each individual particle moving up or
down
so none of the two above quantum
mechanics can explain or
classical mechanics for that matter can
explain
the frequency okay because you don't
have an
object in the case of the waves
you don't have an object in the case of
the quantum particles and in the case of
classical particles you cannot explain
the up and down wavy motion of light
which
is already like ground and stone we know
that's the case
okay and the rope is very easy the rope
is already you know here you
see my famous rope okay it's already
structurally wavy and all you need to do
is torque it
and and you have a three-dimensional
wave
what is waving a physical object called
a rope okay so that's the difference and
then
so when you can see uh coming out of the
prism there you'll see different
colors each one has a different
frequency meaning each one has a
different
wavelength meaning link length the link
of each rope of
the links for a given rope uh
are different in length than uh the ones
for red for blue for the different
colors
so yeah we have no problem with the rope
you know here
assuming uh we'll tighten this up we'll
call this the
high frequency okay high frequency what
is it
uh many torques of the rope
electromagnetic rope
and so we'll call that one blue you want
red which is a lower frequency well you
and torque it
and now you have red okay because they
have
longer wavelength longer linked lengths
we call them
we're done we have a physical object and
now we find
why we have frequency frequency is
simply the link
of a rope okay the the length of a link
of a rope
very straightforward we have the object
and we have
its behavior okay uh the one on the ones
above
don't have either have one or the other
or none okay
okay uh next issue
fellow ass i think it's the same fellow
he says an itinerary is having a plan
for having a seminar or vacation plan
what you intend to do today
has nothing to do with geometry the fact
that i'm saying that itineraries
are what make up each one of these
geometric so-called figures
and again he's just making a statement
uh emotional statement but he's not
answering the question the question is
that all the descriptions
all the definitions of geometry are
itineraries i didn't invent that that's
what geometry
is that's how all these so-called
geometric figures
right that's how they're defined that's
how they're described
they're defined through a construction
they construct these figures
they don't point to them they say let me
show you how i build a circle they don't
point to a circle
and they're still building their circle
because the way they build it they say
between any two locations
you have another locations and they call
them points
okay and even if they use the word point
between any two points you have another
point
and all you do is make it smaller and
fit one in there and so
the circle is still under construction
since the days of euclid they have never
finished building their
circle we're still waiting for them to
finish uh their famous circles so we can
point to it
yeah right now they're still building
they're still putting points between
every
every two points the nfl says the
primary part of this
in uh description of an object is that
it is three-dimensional
the simplicity in it is we can see or
touch
3d and
so here's the question here um here we
have
sierra touch he says let's find out if
that's true here we have
what i showed last time which he doesn't
want to answer
and here we have uh the klingon he's one
gazillion light years away in uh
on the other side of the universe okay
and he's got a table there
okay and he sits on the table or eats on
the table or
crashes it or practices karate with his
table
whatever does his is his table a
physical
object is his physical is his
physical table which is a physical
object does it exist
and again you can't see or touch his
table
and so the question is is that a table
to you
or is it an object to you and and so the
question is if it's not according to
your definition then you cannot use the
definition of c
and touch or 3d that is also a 3d table
so you can't use 3d you cannot use um
what is it see or touch
but does the table have shape
independent of whether you see or touch
it
and the answer is yes the table his
table has shape
and so we we have a definition and
that can be used universally it can be
used consistently
and that is that an object is that which
has shape
an object is not that which you can see
or touch or which is
3d there are 2d objects
they have shape you cannot see or touch
them
depending on what object it is you know
but there are two d
objects that you cannot touch for sure
if you're blind you can't see it and so
does that mean it's not an object
it does have shape so it qualifies as an
object
for the purposes of physics and physics
only
deals with objects that are 3d first
it doesn't have any use for 2d objects
and
more than that it uses 3d objects that
exist
that have location it does not deal with
objects that do not have location
okay okay um
uh here's another comment i think uh
just a summary for this fellow because
it turns out that he doesn't answer a
lot of the questions
one puts questions out there and he just
avoids him runs away and just keeps
asking
the same questions over and over or or
just stating
whatever he learned in high school by
wrote he's just
repeating it regurgitating he says uh
for example
we this is what i'm saying against him
he said
saying we showed that all definitions of
the basic geometric figures are
itineraries
a series of locations i showed that
it's in the definitions it's in the
descriptions i didn't invent all that
that comes out of geometry
geometry defines a circle as an orbit of
a location the location is orbiting
and that's an itinerary that's that's
what a circle
that's how it's defined so answer the
question
okay don't tell me that what i'm saying
is no
use for geometry no that is what
geometry is using there's that's how
they're defining their figure
they're defining it as the orbit of a
location in the case of a circle
then they're defining other geometries
as itineraries which form
a hollow solid and so on these are not
my definitions these are the official
definitions of geometry
so it's not like i'm cheating or that
you can say that
i'm not using that you can't use those
things for geometry that's what geometry
has
so they have an inconsistency don't
blame me this is their problem
the geometer's problem okay and of
course it destroys his religion when you
put that out there because
this is how it's defined and he doesn't
like that he he wants to think that he's
looking at a finished
product and it turns out what he's
staring at is really
a uh a construction of how a geometer
constructs
the figure because all of them are
dynamic
those are all dynamically constructed
and they're still constructing them
because again between any two points you
find another one so they're still
constructing all their geometric figures
this is not my definition these are
their definitions
and so all he does is just repeat over
and over what he learned
by wrote in high school science rational
explanations
first criterion of irrationality you do
not reify
so reification is the first issue there
uh
criterion for finding out what is an
irrational
theory i'd like to extrapolate that and
say that it's an irrational person who
proposes
interrational theory people don't like
that too much
and uh one of them is converting
itineraries into geometric figures which
is the case here
okay you cannot say that you got an
orbit and that you're staring at the
orbit of the earth around the sun and
that that is a geometric figure
no no an orbit is not a geometric figure
okay i don't care if it's a circle an
oval or whatever it is it's not a
geometric figure
geometric figure you point to with your
finger
okay like that there we go you point to
it
okay and this is another comment i make
yeah for this fellow
he never justifies why we need
observation or experiment or
evidence in science okay he just says we
do
well that's because he learned it by
wrote he learned it through uh
what is it authority he just memorized
it for the test or whatever
and you know he believes that because
that's what he learned and that's what
everybody believes out there that he
just has to follow with what everybody
believes
and so it doesn't matter if it's
irrational or not he's going to follow
it on the basis of authority so he never
answers these questions these are the
questions he's got to answer then he
never defended his deficient
his definition of object we told him
okay uh
does the klingon and let me put that up
there again
there it is is
is that table that the klingon has is
that an object
i mean he kicks it he sits on it he puts
his
food on it or whatever is that table
a physical object and you can't see or
touch it because you're gazillions of
miles away
okay and so the question is does that
qualify as an object does the word table
anywhere qualifies an object
and the answer is yes the word table is
always an object in the dictionary it's
uh it's not a concept it's an object and
so
the issue is what is an object and what
is an object for the purposes of physics
and you cannot use the c touch because
again you can't see or touch his table
and that's the answer that he needs to
that's the question he needs to answer
okay okay and so one of them is that he
never answers these questions
he just runs away never defended his
deficient
definition of object uh he claimed to
have a scientific definition
and so i did challenge him in the past
said okay
we showed it to be false right because
there is no
definition of object out there and the
reason there is no one big
definition is that mathematical physics
doesn't care
about um objects
doesn't have any use for objects that's
why quantum mechanics doesn't have any
objects uh to explain
the mechanisms of the subatomic world
they don't have objects they use
equations they use you know these
so-called wave functions and they have
all these terms out there none of them
are physical objects
so you have to define what an object is
because we need to try to give a
physical interpretation
to the subatomic world as well as to the
macro world out there okay so um
you know he claimed to have a scientific
definition what he did is he copied
the definition that he found in the
wikipedia
okay and again it's very easy to tear
down because that definition essentially
goes to the c
touch criteria okay falls back on that
and so there is no definition of object
out there because math has no use for
objects and math is what is identified
as
science today okay and so there never
was a definition because again
mathematic
mathematics has no use for objects or
for genuine
geometric figures that's what an object
is the figure is an object
it has shape if it doesn't have shape
because it's still moving or you're
still constructing it
then it's not an object it's not a
figure
okay uh fella also said bring up
brings up another issue which is
experiments
and he says uh dropping the pencil over
and over which i do
all the time my famous experiment we let
go with a pencil
false to the floor uh pencil over and
over
is a consistent repeatable experiment
okay yeah
and observing that it falls towards the
ground every time okay so we have
observation we have experiment right we
observe
that it falls to the ground after doing
the experiment but a million times it's
got to be repeatable to be scientific
according to these people
now we can make a correct prediction
prediction is a description that's all
it is you haven't explained anything yet
with a prediction
it will fall toward the ground right so
that's a prediction that's all a
description
only a description that's all you said
is it fell to the ground
you can say it will fall or it did fall
in the past it doesn't matter where it's
past the future all you have is a
description
you have not explained why the cause the
mechanism
so far when we let go of that of the 3d
object which we can
see and touch okay you let go of it fine
uh and again uh
see and touch you can't see if if the
klingon does that on the other side of
the plan
of the universe you didn't see it you
didn't touch it
so does that mean what it never happened
yeah you gotta answer the question is
the table is the pencil is the
circle that the klingon has over there
that you cannot see or touch
is that an object that's the question
you gotta answer if you can't answer
that question
uh then all you're doing is just you
know uh
putting your cards in the uh deck
you're just falling uh
short of the explanation that people are
expecting from you you're not defining
the word object
you're trying to get away with uh with
just the authority and that's
all that's all you have and again we can
predict the rate of speed
great again description this is a very
sound theory
so far you have no theory you haven't
explained anything that's what a theory
is
that will probably never change okay
yeah so you don't have a theory
you have not uh a prediction is not a
theory a description is not a theory
theory
is an explanation an explanation is not
a description
and uh
let me get to another one here
give me a second
here we have another uh issue here uh
question a person asks can you please
touch on the issue of
inertia and especially about why
objects in motion stay in motion well
that's an irrational question okay
uh all motion we cannot explain the
beginning of motion
and likewise you cannot explain the the
ending of motion
so when you ask a question why objects
continue in motion or how
objects started motion you're asking an
inter an irrational question
okay motion was there just like
objects are there you cannot use ask a
rational question such as why is there
something rather than nothing
those are irrational questions that
mathematicians
ask because they never understood the
scientific method
that's an irrational question okay so
you don't ask why is there something
rather
nothing and why is there motion or how
do you stop motion or why does an object
continue moving
uh unless uh you stop it uh
there is no such thing motion is a fact
of the universe just like the existence
of objects is a fact of the universe
objects atoms for example cannot turn
into space and space cannot turn into
objects
so you cannot ask those questions those
are irrational questions
and you gotta try to figure out why
those are irrational questions okay
and then uh you mentioned it very
briefly before
in terms of the rope hypothesis well
yeah in terms of the rope hypothesis you
see it there
every atom is interconnected so all you
can talk about
is inertia not not about motion here
we're talking about inertia
and inertia essentially means that you
know you have all these atoms which are
interconnected
and for this you have to look at gravity
okay
and not only why we have mass but also
in gravity
and the important thing here is that if
all atoms are interconnected when you
have that
dancer there she's moving around the
reason her arms kind of uh
stretch out is because she's being
pulled by the stars or you can say that
she's pulling against all the stars
which is a uh notion that was
attributed to uh ernst mach okay german
mathematician okay and um
so what what happens here is that her
atoms are connected to every star in the
universe
and so when she uh feels a tug
she's really in a way pulling against
all those atoms in the universe
and again it's not a pull it's a little
more complicated than that
i use the word pull for quick
way of explaining there is no pull what
it is as an object drifts towards
another
the ropes fan out there is no pull okay
but uh pull is how we identify gravity
we say it's a force of pull
okay so that's the word i'm going to use
unless we clarify exactly
how gravity works okay another um
common question here says
orthogonality is a mathematical term you
not use that in physics orthogonality
separation
of features in a system okay i don't
know what that means
the rpm of your engine and the amount of
fuel you have left are two separate
features
has nothing to do with uh dimensions
which is
i think what he's referring to here and
we track those features on separate
number lines number lines perhaps
not dimensions we don't use uh
dimensions uh
to track anything okay and those number
lines we can add together without
violating the separation of those
features
are dimensions no they aren't they're
not called dimension they're known as
number lines okay
and you're you cannot use the term
dimension without evoking
math it's the other way around you
cannot use the word dimension in math at
all
dimensions are length within height that
that's what those are the three
dimensions there is no other dimension
and those are perpendicular to each
other or orthogonal to each other
paul says it's a mathematical term i
don't know where he got that he's
certainly irrational when he says that
he
obviously he's more ignorant than
irrational i think
now here it is okay this is what
orthogonality means okay
and yeah we don't use math to define
perpendicularity or
uh orthogonality uh it comes uh
from the latin meaning perpendicular
and what that means is vertical it's
based on the plumb line
the plumb line used to be called the
perpendiculum or perpendicularity i
think it was also
and what it is is that um the
[Music]
masons used to have the plumb bob
and they had we used to hang it from a
string or whatever
a little wire and what they did
what they used it for is to make sure
that their walls were straight
okay and what it meant is not that you
had a 90 degree angle
what it is is that it was vertical with
respect to the horizontal plane
that's what it means we don't need any
math any angles
none of that to to define the word
perpendicular
perpendicular simply means that a
vertical stands
vertical with respect to horizontal and
there you see a and b
a line stands perpendicular to c and b
and we need no angles we need to invoke
no angles whatsoever
to explain it's a physical uh notion the
notion
is that one is vertical and the other
one is horizontal that's what it is
and that's what perpendicular means or
orthogonal
so the word orthogonal and perpendicular
do not belong to math they belong
exclusively to physics
what math has done is quantize those
uh quantify them i guess they
started using the word angle and they
started measuring angles
see angle is not a mathematical term
either it's a physical term angle means
simply you know how much separation
there is between two sticks
and they could be nine perpendicular to
each other
you know the standard vertical versus
horizontal
or they could be at uh different
distances with respect to each other
separations
and it's the mathematicians who have
quantified that
okay but it's got nothing to do with
physics itself physics just deals
with the objects and the objects is in
this case
a little abstract that you have one line
per vertical and the other one
horizontal and you can have one wall
which is vertical and the other wall or
the floor that is horizontal
and you don't need any math to
understand that you can just look
stare at that and say okay it's
perpendicular what do you mean by that
well i mean that one is vertical and the
other one's horizontal that's what i
meant
okay very simple so no it's not a
mathematical term
and then uh another question here
another follow brings up
and he says why would the scientific
establishment make up black holes
well the black hole they uh they had to
explain certain features out there and
they explained
two things one was that what happens to
a star
is it collapses on itself
gravitationally
and instead of handling it with reason
with rationality
they decided to do it with math and
that's when they screwed up because they
said well we have mass
so they started using the word mass
instead of objects instead of things
and they say well mass uh this concept
just goes down
goes down to infinity or up to infinity
and we have zero volume and we will call
that infinite
uh as they use it not incessant counting
but they call it
infinite mass and zero volume and we'll
call that thing a black hole
and that's what a black hole is it means
matter has been crushed
out of existence all you have is
location
and nothing at that location and all it
has is
mass which is a concept and that concept
apparently attracts
physical objects such as stars and gases
and atoms and whatever
so that's how it was created and then
they had to explain why stars revolve
around nothing and they said oh we we
figured it out it's that black hole
we calculated mathematically that's
what's in there and that's what
compels the star to go around it but the
issue there is
okay let's assume that's the case how
does it do it
how is the star that's orbiting this
nothingness how is it connected to the
center
of that orbit what physical entity come
comes in contact with the skin of the
star that compels it to go
around in circles around nothing which
they say is a black hole
how does the black hole do it what is a
black hole made of
that is in contact with a star that's
the question
and for that they have no answer so
people have to understand that
the so-called black hole is just a
mathematical abstraction
that has to do with math only and
nothing at all to do with physical
with physics or physical interpretations
okay and final question comment here
phil says what are the holy books and
remars
of mathematics and unfortunately that's
an easy question to answer
the books and grimoires
are known as the textbooks of
high school and college all textbooks
are mathematics
because the only thing that any textbook
of
so-called physics on planet earth to
this day
does is talk about force mass
volume you know energy
things that have nothing to do with
physics physics
is about physical interpretations and
you have to start by defining what an
object is because you cannot do
physical interpretations without an
object not a single
book not a single textbook of so-called
physics on planet earth
begins by defining what an object is
what exists
means and exist is in physics is the
science of existence
so none of the crucial words distance
uh location motion
what is a concept what is space none of
those are defined
in any textbook of physics on planet
earth
okay they have no definitions for any of
those terms and without those you cannot
give a physical interpretation and
that's what physics is about
with that i will see you next time uh
what is it on sunday we'll see you then
bye bye